Some of the right programs say to use a groundy bat, so yes, a lot of them do don't read what it says on the right
Probably you don't have to use a groundy bat with any of the right programs
Accept the foot bath so the iron grow wave is what you really should be using a groundy bat because you got your feet in the water
You want to draw those frequencies through your body. That's the whole idea and the frequencies are going to be attracted to the ground to the groundy bat
to what is groundy them. That's what a groundy bat is. It attaches it to your outlet to the ground
Literally the ground the earth outside. So
The iron grow wave is really the only thing that you need to use the groundy bat with. You can use the groundy bat
We've discussed this at least a hundred times on the zoom calls about the use of the groundy bat
You only need to use it on the iron grow wave
If you're going to use a groundy the groundy sheet in your bed make sure you put it on the lower half of the bed
Underneath the fitted sheet on top of the mattress
Should I be using it during personal programs and during the night and over no just on the iron
Also, I think you said the jackhammer attachment would enable one to be up and about
While still receiving frequencies. Yes, you can if you're using it during the day and you're up and about but still
The treatment range is still only going five to eight feet
So if you're beyond that range, it's not really you're not getting a whole lot of benefit from it
But if you're within five to eight feet from it the majority of time you are getting benefit
So I you know, I really like the jackhammer for that reason we include the jackhammer and our new arrived purchases
But if you purchase it prior to us including it you can purchase one from true right
We don't sell them. They don't give us a discount on it. So you just purchase it right from true right